do you have an Xbox Live Gold
subscription well then you'll be happy
to know that next month's free games
with gold have been announced I'm Matt
and the force is strong with this
GameSpot news update the Xbox one is
adding to three games in May with Gianna
sister's twisted dream being available
for the entire month while Lara Croft
and the Temple of Osiris will be free
from May 16th to June 15th as for Xbox
360 games subscribers will be able to
access Star Wars The Force Unleashed ooh
from May 1st to the 15th and Lego Star
Wars The Complete Saga from May 16th to
the 31st and best of all Xbox one owners
will be able to access this full slate
of games thanks to the consoles
backwards compatibility program and if
you want to stay up to date on all
future games with gold offerings then be
sure to hit those like and subscribe
buttons Gold subscribers who still
haven't claimed this month's games will
still have time to do so
Ryse son of Rome and Assassin's Creed
Revelations are only available until
April 30th but you'll be able to grab
the Walking Dead Season 2 until May 15
you know what you can get for free next
month but if you're looking for a game
to pick up in May then head over to our
Channel and check out the official
character breakdowns for dead shot and
poison ivy and injustice 2
[Music]